[音楽]
マンボウ
にないとはサンタ違う
こんにちは
津川サンタですこれは
タンザニアの公用語の一つであるスワヒリ
語です
私はアフリカの
タンザニアという国で日本の仲間と現地の
人たちと
協力しながら自給自足のまちづくりをして
きました
突然ですが皆さんはマサイ族という名前を
聞いたことがあるでしょうか
西族と聞いて思い浮かべるのは
ジャンプで有名
視力がいい
布を巻くだけの服装そうこの服のことです
よね私のイメージはそうでした
負債の彼らは
伝統の文化を大切にしておりその中に一つ
に
父親の言うことは絶対という考え方があり
ます
結婚相手はが決まっていることもあれば
生まれた瞬間に結婚相手が決まっている
こともあります彼らのことを知る中で一番
衝撃を受けたのはこの言葉です
子供が一人いなくなるのは
牛が1頭いなくなるのと同じこと
だこの言葉を
理解できますか
子供一人と同じくらい牛には価値がある逆
に言うと子供一人は
牛一頭の価値しかない
信じられないかもしれませんがこれは今も
続いているマサイ族にとっての日常です
妻がたくさんいる人ほど男の価値が高いと
される
魔族ではその妻をもらうために
首都交換するん
ですこのように日本とは全く違った
文化や価値観に触れる中で
毎日たくさんの発見と学びがありました
今日は
タンザニアで暮らす中で学んだ人生を豊か
にするヒントというテーマでお話しします
タンザニアに行った経緯は大学時代の2つ
のきっかけからです
一つは教員を目指す中で今の自分は学校
卒業した後に社会で生きていく上でどんな
選択肢があるのか
伝えることができないそれに不安を覚え
より多くの経験を積んだ上で
教育に携わりたいと思ったからです
もう一つは
就職活動の支援をする上でやりたいことを
我慢して安定を求めて世間的に評価が高い
企業に入ることを目的としている人たちを
たくさん見てきまし
たあの頃子供の頃に
描いてた夢はどこに消えたんだろう
いつから自分の可能性を
閉ざしてしまうようになったんだろうと
思いました
そのような経験を通して日本で正しいとさ
れている
価値観に基づいて生きるのが
息苦しいという人たちにもたくさん出会っ
てきました
それを
解決するための一つの手段として日本と
海外をつなげることで日本の価値観が絶対
ではないということを
肌で感じることができる場所を作りたい
自分の軸を見つけて自分の人生にワクワク
する人を増やしたいと考えていまし
たただ
海外とつなげるとなると資金の面が難しい
壁になると感じていました
そんな時に大学時代の友人がアフリカの
タンザニアという国で自給自足の
まちづくりをするという話を聞いて僕は
それに乗っかりました
そんな経緯で
タンザニアに向かうことになりました
仲間と交流した東京ドーム4.2個分の
広大な土地で電気水道食材などを自給自足
する
暮らしをしていました
例えば電気には
太陽光発電を利用しました初期費用は
かかりますが実際に暮らす上ではお金が
かかりません
水道には
井戸水とマサイの牛たちも飲む
池の水を利用しました
食材に関しては予想を拾ったりほぼ毎日
寮に行ったりしてました
ただそれだけでは食材が足りず主食の
うがいを購入してました
さらに
携帯のSIMや
病気になった際の医療費などが必要でした
がそれでもお金がかからないほぼお金が
かからない生活を実現できていました
これだけ聞いてもどんな暮らしをしてたの
かっていうのが
イメージがわかないと思うので1日の
スケジュールをお話しできたらなと思い
ます
1日の始まりはコケコッコという
ニワトリの鳴き声から始まります
毎朝本当に6時くらいに起こしてくれます
朝9時くらいまでは比較的
涼しいことが多いので肉体労働をします
血が一番力を入れたのは水不足をしのぐ
ための
プール作りです
字が鉄のように硬いのでなかなか掘れない
のですがいつも
タンザニア人の一番の友達であるじゃあ
Siriがやってきて手伝ってくれます
彼の力は僕が10人いるよりすごいのでは
という勢いで作業が進みます
実際に3ヶ月かけて
換気をしのぐための5万リットルほどの
プールを
完成させることができました
ここに
利害関係はありません
タンザニア人にとっての幸せは自分だけが
満足することではなく自分を含めた家族や
ご近所さんが
満足している状態のことなんだそうです
だから相手を喜ばせることは自分の幸せに
もつながっている
と写真が言ってくれました
この
タンザニアの友達である
雑誌にの考え方に人生を豊かにするヒント
が
隠されています
相手の幸せのために行動することで結果的
に自分の幸せにもつながります
そして10時頃から朝ごはんの準備をし
ます皆さんは料理をする時どのように
火起こしをしますか
ここではコンロも
IHもありません
でもないものを嘆いても仕方ありません
だからこそそこにある
薪とマッチ棒を利用して
火起こしをしていました
11時半頃に朝兼昼ご飯を食べますご飯に
はタンザニアの主食であるうがいとおかず
には
漁で撮った魚分けてもらったかに住んでき
た野草などを食べて自給自足していました
お昼を食べた後はとても暑いのでゴロゴロ
します
風の音を楽しみながら
読書をしたり
仲間とおしゃべりをしたりします
タンザニアではこのように予定のない時間
が多くこれこそがタンザニア人の心酔いに
つながっているのではないかと感じました
そして
ゆっくりした後は
寮に行きます
1回で23日分の魚やカニが取れることも
あれば逆にほとんど取れずに終わることも
あります食材があるのは当たり前と考えて
いた私はその当たり前の裏側を自分で体験
する中で今までの当たり前にあるものに
気づくことができ感謝することができまし
た
18時頃に夜ご飯を食べて21時とか22
時とかに入れます
こんな
毎日を過ごしながら少しずつお金がかから
なくても暮らせるまちづくりを進めていき
ました
日本では当たり前にあるものが私が暮らし
ていた場所では何もないという状況でし
たただその場所にないものを嘆くのでは
なくあるものに目を向けて生活していまし
た
1日1日を一生懸命生きることに
夢中になる日々でし
たこの生活についてどう思いますか
そんな生活私には無理だと思った方もいる
と思います
確かに物質的には貧しい環境であったかも
しれませんが笑顔にあふれ
幸せな毎日を送っていました
タンザニアではずっとみんなに助けられ
続けてきました彼らがいたからこそ生活を
楽しむことができました
彼らは常に陽気でおしゃべりが大好きです
でも時間なんて守らないし
プライドも高いし
謝らないし彼らには欠点があります
しかしそれ以上に
魅力的に溢れている彼らはいつも幸せそう
に見えるんです
発展している日本が羨ましいっていますで
も発展したことで私たち日本人は当たり前
に生きる幸せ大切な何かを
犠牲にしてそして手放してしまった気が
するのです
それくらい彼らの文化は素晴らしい
ポレポレ世界という
ゆっくりと時間が流れる世界がある
カリブーという相手を温かく受け入れお
互いを
助け合い支え合う文化があると誇らしげに
言うタンザニア人
現に彼らは僕を助けてくれて愛情を持って
接してくれました
言葉も
文化も
肌の色も異なる日本人でも笑顔で歓迎して
くれて何かあれば全力で助けてくれて
初対面でもご飯を分けてくれたり作って
くれたり
タンザニアに来たことそのことだけで喜ん
でくれます
タンザニア人はものはないけど心は豊かで
日本人はものはあるけど心は貧しい
そう言いたいわけではありません
結局どんな場所でも楽しそうに生きる人も
いれば苦しそうに生きる人もい
るっていうことなんです
前の話で
タンザニアの人は幸せそうだったと強調し
て伝えたのにゃわけがあります
それは私たちの
偏見を取り払うためです
日本では
タンザニアを含めアフリカという地域に
対して発展途上国に開拓地などネガティブ
な印象を抱いている人が多いのではないか
なと思います
私はそれを払拭したいと思いこのような
伝え方をさせていただきました
ただ現状として年間を通して安全な水を
利用できる世帯は
約14%しかありません
実際に私たちが暮らしていた地域では
井戸水や雨水の溜まった池の水を生活水と
して利用しており日本と比べた際にお世辞
にもきれいとは言えない状況でした
ただそんな中でも力強く前向きに生きる人
たくさんのパワーをもらいそこで
暮らす人たちのことが僕は大好きになり
ました
また
タンザニアでは91%の子供が学校に通っ
ています
その一方で小学2年生の終わりまでに
読み書きができる子供はわずか23%しか
いません
これは
タンザニアの子供の学力が低いというわけ
ではありません
学校にちゃんと毎日通って勉強することが
できないから
読み書きができる割合がこんなにも少ない
んです
貧困により
授業料が払えず学校を追い出される子供や
家の手伝いをしなければならない子供もい
ます
彼らにとって学校で学ぶことそれは本当に
特別なものです
際に私たちが暮らす街でもイエローお
手伝いをして自国や早退などをする子ども
たちはたくさんいました
タンザニアで暮らす中で
改めて学校教育の大切さを実感しもっと
多くの子供に当たり前に学ぶことができる
環境を届けたい
と思うようになりました
教育を通して学ぶことは人生の選択肢を
増やすことになります
人間は知らないことは選択できません
そして
教育を受けるボトルネックとしてお金の
存在があることも同時に痛感しました
だからこそ自給自足しながら学ぶことが
できる
環境を作ることでどの国でも生徒も学び
ながら生活ができるそんな
環境を整えたいなと思いましたこれが僕の
夢です
最後に
冒頭で述べた
タンザニアで
暮らす中で学んだ人生を豊かにするヒント
についてまとめていきます
今SNSは
毎日たくさんの情報で溢れてますそこには
自分の言ったことのない場所自分の食べた
ことのないものなど自分にはないものが
たくさんありますまた周りには頭がいい人
や
芸術の才能がある人自分にはない能力を
持った人がたくさんいますよね
そんなあなたに伝えたい言葉が一つあり
ます
ないものではなくあるものに目を向ける
何かを手に入れないと幸せになれないわけ
ではありません
そんな決まりはありません
今の自分には何が足りないから
幸せじゃないという考え方をしていると
いつまでたっても豊かな人生を送ることが
できません
いつまでたっても全てを手に入れることは
できないからです
ないものを嘆くのではなくあるものを自分
にあるものをしっかりと見てください
例えば自分を応援してくれてる人であっ
たり自分が今まで人生で頑張ってきた経験
などたくさんあると思います
実際
タンザニアでの暮らしは日本にある
当たり前のものがないばかりでした
ただそこにあるものでどう生きていくか
工夫するかを考えながら生きていくことで
楽しく暮らすことができました
ないものではなくあるものに目を向けて
ください
そうすることで人生が豊かになります
私はあなたの未来を信じています
ご清聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]